how's it going guys matt here from
codetech tutorials wanted to share a
little something that you probably
already know about render doc this is
amazing for graphics programmers if you
don't know about it
you need to know about it immediately if
you do any programming in opengl vulcan
directx
you need to know about this this is
probably
the
most overlooked thing
i have ever
known to be over overlooked i don't know
how else to say it but literally i've
been working on my my little game engine
thing for years and for some reason have
never thought it was a good idea to go
check out render dock although i've
heard it mentioned several times it is
beyond
anything anyone could possibly any thing
i could possibly say
more important
to go get this
and and stop
tweaking your little shaders and rerun
your stuff or whatever the heck you're
doing trying to fix your bug go get
render doc you can you can just tell by
how much i'm i'm pushing this how
absolutely
foolish i feel for not using this like
years ago and years ago
i'm almost mad at my my graphics
programming teacher for not telling us
about this although he probably didn't
know about it and probably still doesn't
know about it because
i don't know for some reason the best
tools in the world seem to go unnoticed
and until it's almost too late anyway
and even if you're not a graphics
programmer even if you're just like a
gamer and are semi-curious about how the
graphics work this is still awesome
because you can run render dock on any
game or anything that's doing anything
on your graphics card and it's going to
give you all kinds of information
about it alright so first of all
obviously you just download it and set
it up you can run it on pretty much
anything and there's uh documents about
it if you're confused about how to use
it but really it's not that complicated
once you launch it i was uh streaming
last night doing some coding and someone
popped in and said hey i see you're
having a little problems with your
lighting have you used render dock
and my answer was although i've heard of
it many times no i'm not let me check
that out so i did and i was just blown
away by what i've been missing enough
hype in it i think you get the point
here i think you know where to find it
let me show you just a little example
about how it actually runs okay so
you've installed it you have the little
thing to launch it and all you do is
just double click it and you get this
window a couple sections here
but basically what you have to do is
launch a program and then tell what to
use
or tell what to look at so
you've got all these sections texture
viewer pipeline state mesh viewer launch
application resource inspector
and honestly i haven't used this quite
enough to be able to explain all of
these in high detail but as you go in
here and play around you'll kind of
start to see it you can even see here in
this pipeline state it even
shows you some some core stuff that you
you're probably somewhat used to
used to seeing so let's just go to
launch application here and let me point
to
well i was testing on seven days let's
let's do it on this before i go to my
own program let's run it on seven days
to die so it needs to know about your
executable i just went to my where steam
apps are installed and seven days to die
and there's the launcher or not the
launcher but the actual program
so
let's let's choose that
pretty pretty straightforward there and
then we just launch it
and it's going to launch seven days to
die of course and you see you get this
stuff up here this is all from render
doc
all right so it says you press f12 or
print screen but all right let me let's
switch to my application
so as you might know i work on a little
game engine called ancient archer and
we're going to check that out so i'm
going to go to my you got to go to the
executable so there's my executable
and i i have the
directories for
for loading up
resources kind of weird so i got to
change this working directory i figured
that out previously so if i go ahead and
launch this
it's going to launch my last successful
build there it is you can see the
lighting problems
you can see it says opengl there
and
i can press f12 and capture the frame
cool well i'll go ahead and close this
now and there's a little frame it
captured
it's got a capture start here's the
color pass
you can see it's got the sky box here
and uh what else does it have a back
buffer color so yeah this is the clear
color we got one texture there's the
whole sky box there
you can see it was a dark sky box and if
we go to this pipeline state go to like
the vertex shader and then view you can
actually see the
the vertex shader as it was written so
that's kind of cool this is kind of a
way to
even if you don't have
access to the shader to a shipped
product you can still go look at the
shader right here which is super cool it
might make for a great example if you're
looking for something uh really specific
all right so let's uh i don't know let's
look at the fragment shader see if we
can view that one too we sure can there
it is and it is my little sampler for
that there's that whole cool thing and
we can go look at something else too let
me close that
you can see all these tabs here
now i wanted yeah this i wanted to look
at this now this is a little ground
plane that was uh on the ground there
and we can also go to pipeline state on
that
check out the shader there you can see
it is and uh yeah don't take too much
example from uh
from these and well you know where to
find them i've got a gazillion videos
about ancient archer and where to find
the source if you want but it's not
going to be the best example in the
world because it's still work in
progress with a lot of bugs so
uh yeah
but the point is
if you're having problems this is the
perfect place to go look because you can
see exactly what it's doing for example
one of the problems i noticed
is i seem to have this error where
i have my specular texture the same as
my diffuse texture so i need to get that
sorted out and i was i've been trying to
figure this out forever so opening up
render dock and just seeing that my
specular texture was set completely
wrong was like oh oh no wonder it's not
working right it's set to the same as
the diffuse so there's just stuff like
that you can figure out in here
and yeah it's like a it's it's basically
just an absolute must-have if you're
writing any sort of graphic software
because as you might know the the
debugging and trying to figure out
what's with what's going on with your
graphics
pipeline is incredibly hard to
sort out but render dock
can uh really give you some details that
are hard to really hard to spot
otherwise so that's going to do it for
this video just pretty quick one just
want to make people aware of render doc
and its capabilities it's
it's just something that shouldn't be
overlooked and i i just
i'm blown away that i've never launched
this
software until last night and i just had
to make a video about it because i'm
sure if i've missed it for this long and
if i've blown it off for this long
although i've heard it talked about
before
i'm sure there's a lot of you out there
who are also in the same boat uh so
hopefully this serves as a motivation
for you to go ahead and grab render doc
when it's free uh obviously and uh
yeah i guess that's about it alright
thanks for watching guys take it easy